so today at work I was helping this
couple I was helping her her it is man
find a swimsuit okay every time I was
asking her what she liked and what color
she liked hey what interjects and be
like I like that one that's the one that
we're gonna get
[Music]
up women would never do that right a
woman would never voice her opinion
about what her boyfriend or husband
wears that's that's something women
never ever do oh sir trunks oh Barbie
those were vintage I myself would never
do that with with my wife I would never
strongly interject with my opinions
about what she's buying not because it'd
be misogynistic to do something because
I just don't care like I don't have any
opinions about it and so anytime she
tries to get my opinion it always it
goes the other way where she's trying to
extract my opinion what do you think
about between this and this and this
what do you like more I don't know I I
honestly don't know I have no idea I
don't know I don't I don't know what
looks better